[Musique]
ce lundi 20 novembre marquait la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant et
dans les Yvelines Michel plusieurs
communes sont engagées pour cette
thématique oui et pour preuve de cet
engagement plusieurs villes ivelinoise
dispose du titre de villeamie des
enfants mise en place par l'UNICEF parmi
elle carrière souspoissie conflan
saint-onorine guyancour marleroi moropam
rambouillé ou encore hencour après avec
près de 300 collectivités engagées sur
le mandat 2000 20 2026 le réseau
accompagne les collectivités locales
pour promouvoir les droits de l'enfant
cinq domaines sont pris en compte le
bien-être la non discrimination et
l'égalité l'éducation la participation
et la sensibilisation au droits de
l'enfant une alerte maintenant l'Agence
Régionale de Santé d'î-de-france
recommande de ne pas consommer les œufs
des poulaillers domestiques oui et cela
en raison d'un niveau élevé de
contamination des œufs par différents
polluants dangereux pour la santé
d'après une étude de l'ARS en
Île-de-France 90 % des œufs analysés
seraient non non conforme des
contaminations sont liées à la présence
dans le sol de polluants organiques
persistants les œufs sont des marqueurs
très révélateurs de la pollution de
l'environnement et en particulier des
sols les recommandations de l'ARS
concernent 410 villes en
île-de-fanceance dans les ielines
plusieurs communes sont touchées c'est
notamment le cas de poissie Mantel jolie
ou encore versaill prunence donc pour
les consommateurs direction maintenant
Rambouillet où les habitants vont
pouvoir très prochainement avoir un un
nouveau cinéma depuis 2019 les
rambolitans n'ont plus de cinéma dans
leur commune depuis la destruction du
Vox si un projet de construction était
prévu après la pandémie en 2021 il avait
finalement été abandonné au grand
désarrois des habitants mais la bonne
nouvelle est finalement arrivée fin juin
2023 la société Sarle l'Ermitage a
racheté le terrain et un permis de
construire a été déposé et signé
l'ouverture au public serait prévu pour
la rentrée scolaire 2025 disposant de
cinq salles le complexe sera reconstruit
sous le Porsche de la rue De Gaulle les
villes de Versailles et Saint-Germain
auolit distingué le site villederêve.fr
a rendu son classement des villes où il
fait bon vivre dans la catégorie des
villes moyennes on retrouve Versailles
en 2e position et saint-gmain la en 5e
position parmi les nombreux critères
pris en compte pour établir ce
classement la qualité de vie le
patrimoine ou encore l'accès à la nature
et à la santé et on termine avec une
information insolite Michel oui une
information insolite et une image qu'il
est tout autant une courge tenez-vous
bien Grégor d' 1,20 pour 44 kg a été
récolté dans les ivlines à l'origine ce
sont des graines de courge musqué
napolitaine provenant d'un voyage en
Italie qui ont été plantés dans la serre
municipale d'olné sur moldre vous vous
en doutez personne ne s'attendait à un
tel résultat Thierry auchard le
conseiller municipal de la commune en
charge de l'environnement et responsable
de la serre a suggéré de faire avec
cette courge une grande soupe pour le
marché de Noël les habitants pourraient
donc aussi en profiter de cette
impressionnante image pour terminer impr
actualité du jour merci beaucoup Michel
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi près
de chez vous vous êtes témoins d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evvelin n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 news